[Music]
we've all felt stressed out at some
point in our lives right
i mean a lot of us feel stressed out
right now while the situations that
cause
us stress may not be as extreme as those
of our cave dwelling ancestors
the effects that stress has on our mind
and our bodies is identical
hi i'm rich burnett for one dream and in
this episode of perspectives we're going
to hear from a handful of experts about
the various symptoms of stress
as well as ways to cope we start now by
learning about a common physiological
response to stressful situations called
the fight or flight response enjoy
imagine that you are walking in a forest
with friends on a sunday afternoon
as you are talking to them not really
paying attention to where you are
walking
you suddenly notice movement just in
front of your right foot
you quickly glance down and see a large
striped snake
coiled and seemingly ready to strike
what's your immediate physiological
reaction
like most people who are afraid of
snakes your heart will start to pound
your muscles will become tense and you
will start to sweat
some people may experience mild forms of
these reactions
just from hearing this description of
the snake
this type of fight-or-flight reaction in
response to threat
was first described by walter cannon a
physiologist at harvard medical school
in the early 1900s
when we first noticed any kind of threat
such as the snake
our sympathetic nervous system and our
endocrine system are stimulated
leading to increases in two hormones
adrenaline
or the more technical name of
epinephrine and
norepinephrine also called noradrenaline
cannon demonstrated that increases in
these hormones in the bloodstream
activate the cardiovascular system
so that blood is directed to the brain
and muscles
this is what prepares someone to either
fight off a threat or
run away more recent findings have led
to important updates to our model of
stress
for example canon's original
fight-or-flight model
was updated to include the possibility
of a freeze response in the face of
threat
becoming immobile generally
all three responses fight flight or
freeze
have one thing in common and that is to
get out of the present moment as soon as
is physically and psychologically
possible
but this exercise challenges you to just
stay in this
probably very unpleasant uncomfortable
threatening situation
and take some time to just check it out
for a minute or two
just stop just be there and see what
happens
for instance if you normally fight when
you're under stress
try to seek connection when a stressful
situation occurs and you
feel your heckles go up before you
pounce an attack
stop take a breath turn to someone you
trust and say
i need help or i don't understand
pause consider your vulnerability
consider your weakness
don't fight don't let your reaction be
defensiveness
come from a place of openness and then
sit in that space of being open
of being vulnerable of asking for help
and just see what happens
if you normally choose flight if you
tend to leave the room
or psychologically leave the situation
by doing something else
then just stop do nothing don't move
don't pick up your phone don't turn to
your computer don't pick up a book
don't even fidget just sit in that
space take a few deep breaths force
yourself to be still
calm and quiet and see if you can figure
out from deep inside
what is really going on why are you
experiencing stress
what is the core of the situation
and if you normally freeze then don't
allow yourself to stop
give yourself three seconds to answer
the question what is one thing i can do
right now
and then immediately do it don't allow
yourself to become paralyzed
remember that movement leads to more
movement even if your first action
doesn't solve the problem
it gets you moving and that puts you on
a trajectory toward addressing the
stressful situation
turn to the situation make eye contact
nod it can be something small but choose
to engage
and note the details of the situation
the point of the exercise is to help you
remember that whatever the event
the event itself is not causing your
stress
what is causing your stress is your
perception of the event
because of habit and tendency you have a
consistent way of behaving
when you perceive stress by changing how
you behave
you can change how you think and feel
and with a calmer perspective and
clearer eyes
you may see the situation differently in
fight or flight humans breathe in short
rapid pulsing breaths
like a sprinter this breathing pattern
helps you in the short term bursts
required for the run
or the fight breathing shallowly enough
and eventually you're holding your
breath all together a potential
positive if you need to be invisible
like during a freeze response
when you breathe you move a little and a
predator's eyes are
drawn naturally to movement the flip
side of this
is also true if you are not under threat
and you breathe in short rapid shallow
breaths you can
activate the survival stress response
and that gets the adrenaline cocktail
pumping into your bloodstream
and remember you don't get any smarter
in this state
and if you are faced with the high-speed
problem-solving reality of escalating
conflict or violence
i want you wicked smart this means
we have to tell your body hey i got this
no need to freak out just yet
and you can train for this with tactical
breathing
slow deep diaphragmatic breaths
the paste breathing of a long distance
runner
or an opera singer place your hands on
your belly
like this basically i use my thumbs and
my belly button is the target zone
after a while when you get this down you
won't have to do this anymore but
starting here is good
this gives you an opportunity that when
you do take the deep breath that i want
you to
you'll feel the diaphragm move we're
used to breathing really shallowly so a
lot of times we need this physical
feedback to tell us
that we're actually getting the deep
breath and then as we do this with your
hands down here
we're going to breathe in through the
nose and
hold it for a four count and then we're
going to breathe
back out again to start with i'll
breathe back out through the mouth later
we're going to change it up a little bit
ready we're going to do this with me
good let's do it again ready hands down
here
and if you're not feeling your belly
move that means you're holding a little
bit
so relax a little bit more without
collapsing that spine so one more
okay cool so tactical breathing
originates from mindfulness traditions
and has a long history of proving to be
particularly effective
it works because breathing in slow
deep controlled breaths creates a signal
that says
all is well it helps mitigate the side
effects of adrenalization
and keeps your thinking self accessible
keeps your vision and your auditory
cutie on deck
and your fine motor skills are still
more viable
with practice tactical breathing can
positively impact the sympathetic
nervous system
in just a couple of breaths work with
this enough
even the first breath in the routine can
begin to de-escalate the rising tide of
your ssr activation
if this is the first time you've
deliberately managed your breathing
start slow so you don't freak out your
sympathetic nervous system
and cause the opposite result a couple
of exercises you can do
firstly a little stretch for the neck
shoulders
and back so if you're sitting in a chair
you'll need to sit up comfortably i'm
going to show you how to do this and
you're going to hold these stretches
for around 15 seconds if you take one
hand
and press it down to the side and take
the ear
to the shoulder we'll start to feel a
stretch through the neck you're going to
do that on both sides
and hold for about 15 seconds
that really begins to release the
tension through the neck
what we then do is take the hands up to
about chest level clasp them together in
front
and just simply press forwards and we
feel the shoulder blades spread apart
the elbows are slightly bent
that's a really good way of reducing the
the tension through the
upper back let's try a um a basic
breathing exercise if you place the
palms on the ribcage at the side
right to right and left to left the
fingers are spread and just as you take
those deep breaths in and out
feel the rib cage expanding yeah
now what i'm going to ask you to do is
to apply a little bit of pressure
with the hands as you inhale you have to
work that a little bit harder now
through the respiratory muscles to
expand the rib cage
and then relax
so try that a few times that'll help you
to relax
through the whole upper body but also it
starts to calm the mind and yoga classes
are a great way to learn more breathing
techniques
in order to aid concentration choose an
object for your
attention for example think of a word a
word that helps you to relax so it might
be
peace or calm whatever it is each time
you take a breath
in think of the word
say it to yourself slowly and make it
last the length of the out breath
okay breathe in as you exhale
say the word make it last the length of
the breath
now you may notice your attention begins
to wander don't try to block out these
incoming thoughts let them come
but then let them go and go back to
focusing on your word
we need more than just stress management
we need life management we need
self-care
and effective strategies that support
our emotional well-being
your energy for life is fundamentally a
reflection of the state of your heart
and your soul your emotional health
determines
your energy levels so above all
treat yourself with loving kindness
hey thanks for watching if you'd like to
learn more about any of the topics in
this episode
the full list of series that these clips
came from is in the description below
you can watch all the full series now on
onedream.com and don't forget to
subscribe to this youtube channel
turn on notifications and you'll get an
alert every time we post a new episode
of perspectives